hey
folks time for the movie retrospective
yeah guess what one we're talking about
today
talking about gargoyles gargoyles the tv
movie from the 1970s
yeah i saw it i saw it on television as
a
kid
i liked it you must have been a little
little kid i mean i think they showed it
later
yeah i think they reached out later you
too you know i mean i remember like
around 76
it's probably around 75 or 76 it was on
there too they you know they replayed it
several times
kind of like they did with uh salem's
lot they were playing i think they
played that a couple times
yeah you know i mean like they do reruns
of it yeah this is actually if
you see any list of uh you know kind of
best tv movies from the 1970s this
usually turns up on most people's lists
now i'm not saying that i mean this
isn't some you know
total complete classic or whatever it's
sort of like you know it's a pretty
cheesy monster movie
but it's pretty fun for 1972 and the
gargoyles look pretty cool
yeah okay let me back up a little bit
all right let me back up a little bit
yeah i gotta take i gotta take the
audience back
to this era this is before okay the
first
the first real convincing [ __ ]
monster i had ever seen as a kid
uh on the screen was uh
alien one and then and predator one came
out when it took its mask off i was just
i was blown away
but it kind of i was basing everything
about realism and how how good a monster
looked
based on this movie this was like the
first movie where you had kind of good
costumes kind of good monster costumes
they were the
they were the feature of this of this uh
little movie
television movie now you have to
understand that
this is before hd so you saw it on crt
tv
which didn't have real good resolution
so some of the weaknesses that you see
in the new streaming versions and in
kind of hd you couldn't see that with
those weaknesses of the costumes
back in the 70s on television you know
what i'm saying it was a lot more it's a
lot more forgiving
seeing it now the movie it still looks
good but it's obvious that they're
rubber suits
yeah they didn't look so they didn't
look so fake
back then and compared to what we were
used to in the 70s
with that resolution i think like the
makeup in the faces
was good looked a lot better than the
body suits
yeah they need there was not enough
muscularity in the bodysuit it looked
like just a man in a wetsuit
with scales pretty much there wasn't any
other features they should have put more
clothes on them
but they were someone's just be a few
days old anyway
yeah it's a good story um
they tell you the whole [ __ ] story
and spoil the end of the goddamn thing
in the [ __ ] two-minute monologue at
the beginning well yeah
at which they narrate the beginning
which
you should never do that you really
weren't even supposed to do that in the
70s
but i think what they're trying to do is
because that science fiction and
horror was so unpopular in the 70s even
on television
that they had to give you some kind of a
hook to keep the audience watching
that's yeah i think that's the only
reason that that's there to make them
interested in it
because horror movies
and sci-fi were really low but it was
really low budget in the 70s and it was
for kids
it really wasn't made for adults it
wasn't really until alien one came out
that horror sci-fi was now for adults
yeah because i think even prior to that
it was more seen as like a teenager
thing yeah kids
well and [ __ ] even throughout the whole
80s it was kind of more seen as a
teenager thing
particularly slasher movies before alien
there were really only two movies that
adults sci-fi [ __ ] that adults liked
war of the worlds
the 1950s version that looked pretty
good remember that one yeah with the
damn
boomerangs you know when it blasted that
preacher i was [ __ ] i was appalled
i was like oh this this is for real
they killed the [ __ ] preacher damn
the martians don't give a [ __ ] about
christianity
and then the one after that the one i
think actually before that i think
was it was also taken pretty seriously
was forbidden planet
yeah it was pretty good parts of
forbidden planet
still kind of hold up okay it does
actually that is actually one of the
best uh
movies of its era if not the best sci-fi
movie that yeah right so
standards were very low in the 70s and
if you're going to come out with a
sci-fi horror
television program you're going to have
to differentiate it from everything that
came before so and and this one kind of
did i remember my dad was impressed with
it
back in the 70s well one like that was
pretty good they didn't yeah and this is
actually like a pretty decent like i
said from today's standards it's pretty
cheesy but
um you have to think too this was 1972
there wasn't a lot of kind of
monster stuff that was made for tv and
also [ __ ] that was made for tv
it didn't it had like a super low budget
yeah so considering how low the budget
was this actually looks pretty good now
it's interesting that
we were talking about the makeup and the
suits and stuff on the gargoyles
so um and it's interesting too that you
mentioned like
predator and aliens and stuff because
the
makeup on the gargoyles was done by a
young
stan winston he actually uh won an emmy
for this and stan winston
most famously would go on to do the
special effects for predator one or two
yeah
terminator one or two okay uh jurassic
park one and three i don't think he did
the second one
uh he also did iron man like and more he
did monster squad he did like a [ __ ]
ton of movies and uh he also directed
some stuff he did pumpkin head he'd i
think he did some liz creepy like
michael jackson videos and all that kind
of stuff well it makes sense yeah he's
super famous dude he's passed away now
but yeah yeah it made sense now you know
i didn't know who he was but this movie
did make an impression in the 70s
yeah and a lot of people still remember
it that saw it it was
not a piece of [ __ ] it was it was good
it the ending is
yeah we'll we'll get into that yeah
the very beginning and the end and the
beginning there shouldn't have been any
narration
all right they had this little narrated
scene it starts out that shows
photographs of the [ __ ] guard old
photographs on
european stuff that may not be there
anymore i don't know [ __ ] creepy old
because it looked pre-world war two the
photographs
yeah maybe that [ __ ] was destroyed in
bombings i don't know
uh look these [ __ ] creepy ass
gargoyles on these churches and [ __ ]
everywhere
and the narrator comes out and says that
like every 500 years these gargoyles
hatch in their reproductive cycle and in
the thousands and come out and try to
take over the
earth but every time they've been you
know defeated every 500 years
and uh you know they're take a lot of
liberties with history
well yeah and a lot of liberty i think
it's one of the weird things about this
movie one of the things that i find
really weird
is that in the first you know opening
narration like like you said there's a
lot of pictures of you know like notre
dame cathedral and stuff you know all
the gargoyles on there
and uh there was a still from uh hexane
that uh silent movie in there too
i saw that but um i'm not really sure if
they knew that that's where it was from
or they just found it someplace
but they are basically um conflating
gargoyles with demons like satan's
minions or whatever yeah and that's not
really what they were yeah but then like
in the actual movie so it almost kind of
feels like that
that you know preamble was sort of like
an afterthought because in the actual
movie the gargoyles are like you know
kind of bad guys
but they're not that evil you know what
i mean they're
just another species yeah they're just
like another species that's just trying
to like
but well i've got to back up on that
the narration okay one of the things
that's a little that's a little
different about this story
if you're going to narrate it then they
they went
[ __ ] they leaned into this [ __ ] they
go ahead and say
christianity is real the devil actually
exists
these are his creations yeah all right
and that these that these things
basically worship the devil
and try to take over for the devil and
what's weird is that during this collage
of
and then they'll show [ __ ] from like
bosh's paintings you know yeah
which all that [ __ ] was cool and at the
very end
they actually spoil the monsters they
show its face they never should have
done that never spoiled the monster
they spoiled your [ __ ] maid monster
your main gargoyle
spoiled it right there in the [ __ ] in
the first
minute of the movie so they clipped the
movies nuts off
you know already well you know that i
know that it's just television and they
probably weren't taking it seriously
and probably know the station demanded
that the television network demanded
that
and they grafted that in there because
you could easily
take that out and this [ __ ] would
because i kind of feel like
i mean you do get to see a lot of the
gargoyles in this and there are a lot of
different gargoyles and they all look
different
which i think is cool like they make all
of the you know they all look vaguely
reptilian or you know whatever but they
all have their own look to them which i
thought was cool reptiles they had
reptile monkeys [ __ ] porcupine one
looking ones
and some of them just look like demons
with wings and [ __ ]
yeah and monkey eagles they're kind of
like griffins
where they're cros part monkey with like
an eagle beak on it
they look pretty cool they're like
something up they were inspired by the
statues
you know yeah and they kind of looked a
little bit like the flying monkeys from
the wizard of oz yeah
a couple of them did but what i was uh
what i was saying was that
you know you get to see a lot of them
you know over the course of the movie
but when the movie starts you don't see
them for a walk they kind of build up or
they just like show a shadow like on a
mountain or something like that so
you know that's why i kind of feel like
that little uh you know collage thing
and the narration at the beginning was
probably pasted on
as an afterthought because it did seem
like the movie was trying to be like oh
what's this that's following them around
even though obviously the is called
gargoyle so you know yeah yeah they
spoil the [ __ ]
they should have called it something
else like winged evil or
something it's a pretty cool little
flick well they're trying they're
begging you to watch them
they're big come on it's charged
the movie is basically a cross between
hills have eyes and planet of the apes
but the
the but the planet of the apes they
would be demon demonic plant
of apes be like that some of some of
whom can fly
they can't all fly just some of them you
got like this anthropologist
and his daughter he picks her up at the
airport or the other way around it
didn't really matter she's wearing the
most
hideous 70s outfit of all times
you guys he spent half the movie
analyzing why the hell
about her outfit first of all she was
the
she was kind of like california girls i
grew up with you know down
you know when i was a kid and they were
all in their late teens early 20s down
sierra nevada
mountains down sequoia running around
nudists and [ __ ] just [ __ ]
[ __ ] with the tube tops and the tank
tops and
no tops and nip slips and [ __ ] all
kinds of weird [ __ ] and they would just
undress in front of you it was bizarre
it was another time but it was just the
way hippies were
so she had this terrible top on and
these [ __ ] skirts that they used to
wear about themselves they were like
denim
and they had slits going down the front
and everything was high-waisted and it
was just ridiculous
i remember they wore those things around
but underneath them usually was a bikini
top they just they mostly took those
things off
they were kind of like beach wear she's
wearing that and flip-flops
and she's wearing this with her dad and
they go fight [ __ ]
gargoyles out in the damn desert when
she's wearing basically halter tops
through the whole
whole thing pretty much yeah yeah and
the [ __ ] gargoyles were interested in
the hollow
in the halter top one of them was
grabbing her boobs
well implied he was kind of hovering
over because i was like hey
this is this is cbs this is network tv i
can't i mean they're showing it at 9 30
in the
angle and [ __ ] you know i know he's
grabbing her but he's kind of like oh
yeah there's nothing real nothing
really about the story it's kind of it's
kind of like this a
similar story to hills have eyes they go
out to the desert
um bad [ __ ] happens they get attacked by
this old first of all this all they're
investigating this old dude
and this old duties like this
stereotypical minor 49ers yeah well
thanks for coming and i got all of this
look at this no it's the real thing you
know michael willy
uncle willie yeah he has one of those
kind of uh yeah little museums
museums on the side of the room they
show you monkey fish and [ __ ] like that
mermaids there's like old refrigerators
and cars up on blocks
in the back i got the real thing i'm
gonna show it to you you know
that's why i called you we're gonna
write this book together
and he's got the skeleton of a [ __ ]
gargoyle it's got wings and [ __ ]
head with i need because i need to have
this carbonated but the dude that's
looking at me goes oh you just pieced
together a bunch of animal bones and
human bones that's fake and he's going
no no no this is the real thing you know
and while they're trying to cut a book
deal he's well i'm going to take the
head the head was pretty
bizarre it was i could tell it was a it
was a it was a steer's head would they
change the horns
did they change the horse and they took
the teeth out of it put a big beak on
the front of it you know
and um while they're trying to cut the
book deal
the the [ __ ] barn that they're in
gets attacked by the damn gargoyles
and they're trying to get the skeleton
and they kill uncle willy and set his
ass on fire and
dude and his daughter [ __ ] run out
they indirectly kill uncle willie
because they just kind of [ __ ] out
the shed the roof beam falls on him and
then
then a lantern falls off then a lantern
falls on him i'm like not it wasn't
uncle willie's day
no i can just hear him going dang damn
it yeah
they run off they run off and [ __ ]
her dad has got the damn head
still to to the skeleton and they go to
the local
uh uh what do you call them well they
well they get attacked by
gargoyles first because it [ __ ] up
their car that's cause they wreck the
car
fighting on the car yeah jumps on the
car and [ __ ] and then they have to go to
the gas station to get the car fixed
and so then they have to stay in the
motel because their car is like super
[ __ ] up
yeah so they have to go stay at the
motel run by it was a pretty good scene
yeah that's fun
it was a pretty good scene for the time
you know the gargoyle was riding on top
of the car it was pretty good stunts
especially for television at the time
it was actually like you know can you
imagine having all of that
suit and that makeup on and just having
to like jump up and down like over this
moving car and [ __ ] like that so yeah
props there so to go to this uh cheap
motel and living in there
father and daughter in this room and the
the the the
woman owning the hotel is she's the lush
she she's a lush she's drinking she's
trying to get laid by the old dude
he's blowing her off and then the
gargoyles attack that rim to try to get
that skull
all right and they run out with the
skull
and uh he's chasing them and three of
them are running out the front door and
the last
very last one tries to cross the street
and get hit gets hit by a truck and he
jumps
he jumps on it and looks at it he makes
eye contact with it and it dies
so they lose the skull but they got the
whole body now so they feel like
yeah the owner of the place starts
attacking what are you guys doing you're
tearing my [ __ ] up
what was all this noise why are you
fighting and they they hide the body
they don't want her to see it doesn't
make any sense i'd show it to her so
look this is what
yeah this is what was oh we didn't do
this do this [ __ ] but don't charge me
for this crap
back in the 70s you know what i mean you
protected the you protected the identity
of the monster because no one would
believe you even though you have the
monster
well that's another thing too is that
when let's not show them they'll never
believe us
you know what are you talking about you
have the [ __ ] body
yeah it's quite ridiculous but yeah i
mean i can see that yeah they wouldn't
believe you if like you know they just
they all took off
they had a damn body but they had a body
in which case
if [ __ ] man if i had a gargoyle body got
hit by a truck and i had it in the hotel
i would be showing every [ __ ] that
yeah well yes
that's the thing too is that so they
don't want to show like the thirsty lush
lady at the
motel like with her [ __ ] robe and her
curlers yeah
so sexy but um it was a house coat
actually yeah
oh padded house quilted out when you
were a little kid
your grandma's grandma wore that [ __ ]
yeah with like the little pink curlers
in her hair
and she was like taking them out like oh
i have to look presentable for my
gentleman collar
yeah it was like that kind of thing but
so so the next day like of course
you know uh dr foley and his daughter
diana i don't even think we said what
their names are through the main
characters
um you know since uncle willie got
killed in his [ __ ] shed
so i was like does it occur to you that
maybe you should go to the police
because you're gonna get blamed for that
[ __ ] yeah
um but it happens it so happens that the
cops decide they're going to blame
it on this gang of well i don't know
gang that's that's kind of
they're just a group of dudes they're
just a group of dude it's not a game
dirt bike on dirt bikes
one of whom is played by scott glenn for
chrysler that's that guy's name
yes yes he was like it's probably like
the the most recognizable one and a
bunch of westerns and [ __ ]
yeah and he was he was in silence of the
lance too yeah
he played the head of the uh yeah like
he was uh clarissa's uh boss
yeah that's right but yeah so that's
where i remember him both from but yeah
he's been in [ __ ] ton of westerns as
well
yeah and then it gets kind of convoluted
around this point they're trying to fill
some time
and it turns out that they eventually
convince the police and the motorcycle
gang
that there's this cave
in the side of a mountain and then
there's a big nest of eggs and these
sucking gargoyles
hatch and they're underneath the earth
and every 500 years they come out
now they captured his daughter and took
her in there
during all this they got the girl yeah
and and he's
the main gargoyle's trying to get her to
teach him how to read these books
well no he just wanted her to read them
he was having her
read the books well yeah because he's
like i'm too lazy to read you you read
to me
and they were only a few days old yeah
they were they weren't very old and they
i guess they had race memories because
they could speak when they woke up
and they knew the history of their race
but they didn't
they didn't know much about human beings
they wanted to know more about what the
hell was going on
and uh he had her reading stuff about
incubuses and about women who were
surrendering to inky buses and [ __ ] and
then he's like oh he's like yeah
it's gonna happen that's
gargoyles can impregnate human women and
they can have offspring
and he was and then the his female
gargoyle was getting girl his girl
girlfriend was getting pissed at him
because
he was messing with this human woman too
much and he was trying to be nice to her
but you could tell he'd be evil every
now and then
[Laughter]
the evil would just sleep yeah his evil
would come out do i i love
the scene where they you know they
kidnap diana and they take her back to
the caves where all the other because
there's
there's like a handful maybe like a
dozen gargoyles there already but then
they're all like a bunch of eggs so
they're waiting for all the eggs to
hatch
and um so they're in the cave and
uh the main gargoyle's wife i guess
like comes in there and she's all female
yeah she's like all pissed off she's
like you know what's that little [ __ ]
doing in here or whatever you know kind
of thing
and he's just like oh it's okay honey
what if he doesn't talk but he's just
like hugging they're doing some kind of
mental thing
and then like and then when she turns
around
that's it smack [ __ ] hey
gargoyle wife is great just
don't worry you pretty little gargoyle
head about it it's so [ __ ] funny
it was perfect i just died laughing it
was perfect for the tone that they were
trying to
tell that these were that these were
they were you know he was an incubus
of course but uh
i was like seriously i [ __ ] died
laughing at that part
i'd seen this movie before but it had
been a long time and i had completely
forgotten about it
the special effects inside the cave are
pretty good looks like it might have
been filmed at carlsbad caverns they
were in a real cave
the eggs and [ __ ] looks cool yeah the
eggs the egg
room looked like it was taken out of one
of those old 1960s
uh like a high budget 1960s british
movie like you know voyage to the center
of the earth or something like that yeah
like the lighting and children yeah the
lighting and the scene kind of tone
or it looked like star trek a little bit
like slightly like star trek they were
the big eggs would hatch and a little
kid would come out like
in in a gargoyle garden petting on him
it's all right he's coming up
[Laughter]
they're bringing new ones into the world
you know there could be thousands of
them
and uh so the cops the motorcycle gang
go down there and deal with the damn
gargoyles yeah because they have to get
the diana back you know
yeah there's gargoyle fights and [ __ ]
gargoyle shootings and the horses are
involved
gargoyles like smack a couple [ __ ]
off their dirt bike yeah yeah turn over
a couple cars
yeah this is what they do
the gargoyle suits look pretty good
especially for the top for the time
yeah yeah yeah but if you were just
running around in them
it would just look like a japanese
monster movie like something out of them
uh uh what what what's what's the word
i'm thinking of
being [ __ ] power rangers it looked
like something out of power rangers yeah
it was so what they would did
is that they slowed everything down so
whenever you saw the gargoyles moving or
running
they had it in slow motion to make it
look a little
less rubbery i think because the little
things on them would probably wiggle
because they had wings and [ __ ] you know
yeah and it would probably look kind of
comical
if it wasn't slowed down and when you
slowed them down they were trying to
make them look like they had a little
more gravitas
i guess sarah they wanted to make them
look more unearthly or something i'm not
really sure it was
probably a better pretty effective
compared to if you saw in normal speed
you just see a dude in a rubber suit
yeah that would look like my clutchy ass
running around like a monster suit
yeah i'm trying to think about what
happens
they rescue the girl he gets pissed
because the
demon loses his girlfriend uh the dad
rescues her
which is weird because you got the dad
almost kind of like in the [ __ ]
leading man
thing and it's all it kind of felt kind
of incestuous
i mean i did like that then a leading
man rescuer not the dad
yeah you know what i mean i always yeah
i always wonder why they do that type of
thing because
it's kind of reminded me i know this
might be kind of out of left field but i
only just thought of it
this sort of reminded me of that old
caveman
movie i think did roger corman make it
called eaga and that was a
that was a father and daughter too and
man that was
really weird like the [ __ ] [ __ ] that
was in that she's like you know
there was a thing where ega like kidnaps
the dad
and then she gets kidnapped too or they
both get i don't know i haven't seen in
a long time
but there's this kind of thing where
she's like oh i'm gonna like sit on my
dad's lap and like shave the
caveman
one thing that i did notice that they
did was when they checked into the um
hotel or you know run by the drunk lady
um they actually did get two separate
rooms yeah so
it wasn't like they were sleeping in the
same room because that might have been a
little weird yeah but um
yeah i did kind of wonder about that i
don't know it just seemed like a strange
dynamic it wasn't too creepy
it wasn't like he got level creepy but
you know what i mean it's just like it
was kind of like why is he saving her it
should have been the
the the motorcycle guy should have been
the one that saved her yeah see that's
what i thought they were setting up
because
you know the motorcycle guys they got
blamed
for killing uncle willie or setting the
fire that killed him right now there's
been a traditional like
love interest thing too yeah and then i
thought it was coming so they got locked
up in the jail
and then um diana like went to the
police station like ran to the police
station in the middle of the night was
like hey let them out they didn't do
anything it was the gargoyles that did
it but of course they didn't believe her
so so yeah and then she was like talking
to him and being like yeah there's
monsters and maybe you should yeah i
have i haven't
i have a funny feeling that that's how
this story was originally going to go is
that maybe like
he was going to save her and then they'd
go off in the sunset for maybe some kind
of
contractual or some kind of ego lessons
the older ego reasons the older guy goes
oh no i have to be the hero
in the contract it says i'm the hero
yeah it might have been something maybe
that's what it was
yeah maybe because i would have thought
yeah like you said usually stories like
this
it would go like the dad would like
sacrifice himself maybe for example
like for her to live and then she'd run
off with yeah motorcycles and then the
motorcycle guy saves her
saves her and then it ends up like the
[ __ ] video aha you know
yeah yeah you like that yeah sure that's
what i thought it should do no
that's the way it would have gone had i
wrote this [ __ ] well like i said that
is the more standard monster movie
yeah usually the old guy dies guys
because it's almost kind of like oh
he's the only guy he's being replaced
but it's like the weird
thing where your dad gives you away at
the wedding it's like that's like i feel
like it's that kind of
no yeah the dad's self-sacrifice besides
the older generation's gotta go and the
new generation comes in that's all it is
yeah
yeah so i so i do kind of feel like
that's usually standard how it goes
yeah but it didn't go that way in this
one i think they everybody lives except
some of the
uh motorcycle guys get killed by the
gargoyles maybe do some of the cops get
killed too i think
yeah you know you know it's gonna get
killed yeah so it's so i think some of
them get killed but it was nobody whose
name you knew so it's like
didn't matter nobody worried about it um
you know all the named characters like
they came through okay
now the weird thing about this i'm not
sure if this is true or not so this
movie wait hold on what we didn't talk
about the end
well that's what i was just gonna get
that's what i was gonna get what i was
gonna say was that
this movie actually first premiered it
was on cbs it was like their 9 30
p.m like tuesday night movie because i
guess you know how abc used to have
movie of the week and that was like a
really big thing
so this was like cbs's um attempt to
like compete with that they did like a
tuesday night movie or whatever
and uh so they wanted to do [ __ ] that
was like more lurid i guess
because the abc ones were mostly like
murder mysteries and [ __ ] so they want
to do like some monster movies so they
could have their own
kind of thing going now i heard and i'm
not entirely sure if this is the case
and this ties in with the ending that
we're going to be talking about a second
i heard that this was supposed to be a
pilot
for a series that made sense that's the
end the ending kind of
sets up said sets that up because the
ending of this is
very abrupt yeah um and most of the
others there's not a lot of other
reviews of this
but uh i think cinemassacre reviewed it
um geek legion of doom remember
this i think they reviewed it and both
of them said the same thing they're like
the ending of it it's just it just stops
just answers and here's the thing
it was going kind of like a reversal of
the planet of the apes theme yeah
and that was they made a series out of
that too some people said the television
series is pretty good
i've never seen it i've seen it but it
was a long time ago somebody wants to
send me the series i'll watch it we'll
review it
but um yeah i just it seems like they
were setting up a series
they left it unclear whether or not all
the eggs were destroyed
yeah because they went in there and kind
of scott glenn went in there and burned
all the eggs like he poured gasoline
one can he had he had one and a half
cans yeah one and a half and there's
just
thousands of eggs even though there
clearly wasn't yeah clearly
clearly it was like a couple of dozen
eggs that he burned up i mean they
didn't have the budget
what happens at the end is that the
[ __ ] dad sure wounds the
the gargoyle's girlfriend like her wings
and she can't fly
so which makes him have to evacuate her
by leaving and they had this [ __ ]
scene
this was a big deal back in the 70s
where he picks her up and flies away
through the
that's the only time that you see the
gargoyle yeah you see him with the wings
flying and he's carrying her
it looks very mediocre by today's
standards
um superman won with chris reeve that
flying was a lot better but they were
trying to do something like that i mean
the flying in that still looks pretty in
the flight yeah still looks pretty good
um but this and it's just a shot of him
and it's real dramatic like you're
seeing some heavy [ __ ]
look he's flying and i'm going like boy
i
wonder what wonder what that [ __ ] that
wires on a crane
yeah it would have had to be yeah and
it's nothing really impressive
you know it's just not really but like i
said for a tv movie in 1972
that's why they waited until the very
end to show because they
they didn't like i said they didn't all
have wings i think only i think they
said only the breeder ones had wings
yeah the ones like i guess the other
ones were like drones or whatever
yeah they were like the army ants yeah
so like the other ones did have wings so
they didn't all but they didn't show any
of them flying
here's the reason why i think maybe they
probably didn't make a series out of it
because i was during the final scene
it's very apparent that these gargoyles
are are not that capable they're not
much more capable than a human
some of them can fly they're strong
enough to pull the car door off
um they have claws but they're not
bulletproof
the cops are just shooting them yeah and
they don't have weapons or anything yeah
10
000 of them would mean nothing to an
army you just mow them down with m16s
yeah it's not i think it might have been
they might have been scarier if they had
some kind of like magic powers or
something
or they could shoot something or they
had to grasp on technology
yeah something like that i could see how
they would have been a familiar
formidable army maybe in the 1500s when
you were dealing with singles yeah
before people
got you know single shot musket type
match locked you know but in
in the age of [ __ ] armored vehicles
flame throwers and [ __ ] automatic
weaponry and bombs and aircraft now
these things would be annihilated
well yeah especially because like i said
it's only every 500 years
yeah there's just a few thousand of them
in one cave in nevada somewhere
it's like as long as somebody found him
in there and just like blew the [ __ ]
cave up
yeah sorry for another 500 years but
that's the thing i i think
that even though the head gargoyle who's
played by bernie casey by the way
um who was i he was in some other [ __ ]
later on but i can't remember what it
was
but um you know he even though he kind
of comes across
as sort of evil like he's sort of a dick
but he's not entirely bad though and
in a way you can kind of sympathize with
the gargoyles because they're not
you know even though gargoyle gonna
chicago yeah gargoyle's gonna go
you know what i mean and so it's just
kind of like at the beginning they're
kind of oh demons and blah blah
but it's like they're just another
species that are trying to
dominate their environment just like
every other species does so you kind of
feel bad for them
like especially when you see like the
little cute baby
gargoyles like coming out of the eggs
and then later they go in there and just
burn all the eggs up and i'm like oh the
baby coils oh no
you know what i mean funny is that he
was kind of sadistic he was kind of
funny he just pushed the dude
remember that that made me laugh a lot
even just pushing [ __ ]
down some [ __ ] i mean he didn't even
have to do that yeah
he was just kind of like [ __ ] they used
some kind of effect on the voice
that did not carry over too well to the
digital copies it sounds like
vi sounds like static happening in the
background yeah it was like a weird like
vibration
they talked about they were talking
through something and it was recorded it
was not digital it was some kind of
analog device that made that sound that
type of voice and that voice
was not impressive by today's stan it
wasn't even really that impressive by
the standards of the 70s
they could have done much better voices
for them um
but uh it's just it was it was good it i
could see how it was like might have
been a pilot
monday dc pilot for a series that
probably wouldn't have gone very far
um yeah because like at the end they
kill most of the gargoyles but then
the the head guard gargoyle and his
girlfriend who's one wing is
missing the dad uh you know dr
like mercer whatever dr foley um mercer
is his first name
but he's kind of like oh well you know i
wounded her but it's like here i'll give
you two a chance because y'all can breed
um but i'm killing all the rest of these
[ __ ] because which seemed to me
like pretty fair
you know what i mean because he's like
it's just another it's not their fault
that they're gargoyles you know what i
mean
the thing is is that the gargoyle system
i don't think it made a good series it
barely made it really it made a good
monster movie barely
because they got their asses kicked
pretty badly
we were just born oh yeah we all got
shot
maybe the same could be said for the
aliens out of alien like the xenomorphs
yeah ripley was like oh if these things
get back to earth it's all over you know
the earth would be
destroyed now the marines shot them up
pretty bad too
as long as you can get to the queens you
can keep them down you know but
you could also say what made the aliens
from the xenomorphs a little more
threatening is that
evidently even a worker alien could turn
a human being
into an egg and then an egg yeah i think
that was kind of their main superpower
yeah like a queen could lay an egg
but if you read the very what what they
had cut out of the originally alien one
it grabbed
dallas and tick him up in a thing and
and dallas was being
absorbed and consumed and transforming
into an egg
yeah now that egg might have had a queen
in it so anybody could make a queen
under the right conditions
yeah to me that's that's what makes them
scarier and more formidable
they can reproduce right these things
really you know
they they'd lay eggs but they'd lay
dormant for 500 years
that's a long time to use a long time to
find them eggs and destroy them
yeah i mean it seems like it doesn't
seem like a very good system
they weren't reproducing quickly so
need to be wiped out yeah which means
that's why it never became a series
yeah you know it's it i don't know where
you could go from there it's like you
kind of have to follow like the main
gargoyle couple
right and then maybe it would be oh they
should have turned it into like a comedy
where the gargoyles were like trying to
like
conceive the next generation of
gargoyles
if it was something like that one of
those bosch paintings where they're just
spilling out of the ground in a huge
[ __ ] wave
where it's not hundreds of thousands of
them it's hundreds of millions of them
and like i said they can't destroy them
all they needed powers other than they
could fly
they could you know like spit acid or
something
you know what i mean it's a bunch of
stuff yeah or like you said they had
like some kind of [ __ ] weird
thing they reproduce with humans quickly
yeah something like that
yeah the most ripley worried about the
xenomorphs getting back to earth would
be nothing compared to worrying about
the thing getting off of antarctica
because if the thing got out you those
you everybody
we'd all be [ __ ] yeah you could think
about it you couldn't stop the thing
that'd be that's a superior alien right
there
just absorbing and mimicking everything
yeah because you'd never know where he
was like i said that's
that's why i would argue that the thing
is probably the scary that's the worst
that's the worst because you would never
know yeah it could go eat it could
absorb jenny and then come in here and
walk it
walk walk in here as jenny knowing
everything about jenny and i wouldn't
even know that she shouldn't have a
future face
and then in an opportune moment she'd
just get me a copy of me
and there'd be two of us and then
pookies grab poop and then it'd be a
pokey thing
because remember the dogs so whenever
they transform the thing you see faces
of the dogs in there
yeah and then crab legs from other
planets oh my god pookie could be a
thing right now yeah
she's just in there sleeping in the cat
tree pocahontas
that's why i called it that pocahontas i
started laughing
i said she needs a little headdress or
something yeah oh i just remembered the
guy that played the head um
the head gargoyle bernie casey he was in
in the mouth of madness that's what i
was thinking about really who do you
play in the mouth
[ __ ] man now i can't remember he had so
much [ __ ] makeup on him that should i
have to look up in space again i can't
remember
but there's a couple of people in this
like the old dude in this that played
uncle willy he was in
devil's reign which we really need to
review that one of these days because
that might be hilarious with william
shatner
and also uh what's her face that played
diana i think her jennifer salt i think
her name is she was also in sisters the
brian de palma
movie which is another one that i want
to review because that was really good
that had margaret kitter in it as well
we were talking about that the other day
uh and that's actually really good but
yeah um so this movie
it's pretty short i think it's only like
an hour and 15 minutes
like i said it's it's you know it was
for tv yeah
and uh it's just a fun early 70s
slice of monster movie cheese you know
from 70s tv
so you know if you're into that and you
want to see some early stan winston
makeup effects then by all means check
it out i think it's on it's on 2b
right for free yeah might be some other
places too but yeah you can watch it on
there for nothing if you want to
and that'll do it for this review unless
you have anything else you would like to
add
okay well then we'll see you on the next
one bye